okay so since the inside of my friend
just so baffling and I saw all these
news reports I'm gonna give you guys a
tour of my fridge Kim Kardashian is
giving fans a tour of her refrigerator
and guys it's wild it's amazing
frigerator where we keep all of our
fresh organic produce we are building on
the property all organic
trees to grow our own vegetables really
fast this all started after Kim posted
this pic making people think all she had
in her fridge was basically a whole lot
of milk okay
back to this tour it's not just a fridge
it's multiple fridges pantries and
freezers so you'll come into my pantry I
hope I got rid of all my plastic so it's
all like glass jars even all my
sprinkles and stuff for my frozen yogurt
all of that yeah she said her frozen
yogurt because well just watch so you
come from the pantry all there is is the
frozen yogurt machine it's all the
little snacks my freezer and then I got
rid of all plastic bottles so I just
have this for right now it's just my
drink fridge all my kids use a different
kind of milk with you guys my fresh
juices fresh water that's all that's in
this fridge this is all truly insane but
guys there's more this is the kitchen
where it all happens
say hi marina and guys I have
walk-in frigerator where we keep all of
our fresh organic produce we are
building on the property all organic
trees to grow our own vegetables and do
all of our own stops so this all of our
meals you guys know I eat plant-based
now so all of our stuff is in here so it
did look like an empty refrigerator that
I took the photo in front of I have to
admit but this is our big main
frigerator guys and still there's even
more I also have another pantry because
this is the kitchen that we cook in look
at look what I have for dinner tonight
guys vegan tacos this is all plant-based
what I'm eating tonight know this
deliciousness then if you want a little
more chaos with tons of oat milk and
almond milk you have this frigerator
wait can we talk about how her stove
literally looks like the stoves that
they use in restaurants okay
if you want freezer I didn't even show
you guys are other freezer there you
have it guys we'd also like to point out
Kim doesn't say refrigerator during this
tour just frigerator or fridge seven
times the inside of my fridge is my
fridge you have this frigerator
refrigerator is just my drink fridge but
this is our big main frigerator guys
frigerator now this isn't the only peek
inside Kim's house that we've gotten
that remember sink gates and the
bathroom door okay so since everyone's a
little bit confused about our sinks I
thought I would just show you guys a
little tour of our
bathroom that's our patio out there
our whole ceiling is a light box again
so wild bathtub that fits all of our
kids and our shower so okay so the sinks
Kanye drew this Kanye Axl vibora and
Claudio Sylvester and kind of all did
this sink and Claudia was the one that
said it should be separated from the
wall because it used to be up against
the wall but we thought it would be
cooler this way so eight versions of
this prototype sink was made and it does
actually like slightly sloped down that
you can kind of see and there's a slit
for the water all I have to say about
this though is when can I move in baby
of course obviously Kim and really the
whole Kardashian family are no strangers
to extravagance
well we actually just went on a private
vacation when we were we had a six-week
break from filming and we I was case you
were wondering Chloe had never been
before so it was really exciting to see
and just to have this like private
vacation just us sisters with our kids
they all had so much fun together but
nothing will ever be as extraordinary or
extra has Kim's fridge fridge rater all
right guys that is it for today for all
the way to stun Kim and her fridge stick
with all things et until next time I'm
Katie Krause and bye for now
[Music]